the 94th annual academy awards ceremony
will undoubtedly go down in history as a
memorable moment in hollywood but
unfortunately not because of the
incredible talent honored at the event
instead what immortalized the night in
the public consciousness was king
richard star will smith striking chris
rock across the face and cursing him out
from the audience after the comedian
made a reportedly ad-libbed gi jane joke
about his wife jada pinkett smith's hair
jada has been open about her hair loss
and alopecia since 2018. now this is
going to be a little bit more difficult
for me to hide
it was a bewildering moment that
immediately drew strong reactions from
other celebs in the industry as well as
from the public at large in another
shocking twist smith won the academy
award for best actor for his role in
king richard after the altercation and
sobbed through a six-minute acceptance
speech to a stunned and uncomfortable
audience in the dolby theater though
rock is declining to press charges
against smith their dust-up may have
lasting repercussions for smith
nonetheless the academy of motion
picture arts and sciences issued a
statement on twitter condemning violence
of any form just after the ceremony had
concluded suggesting the possibility
they might take some form of action
against the newly minted oscar winner
many vocally called for smith's oscar to
be revoked and internally abc and
academy representatives discussed
removing him from the show now we
finally have some notion of how the
academy is choosing to proceed thanks to
a new statement about the incident which
read the academy condemns the actions of
mr smith at last night's show we have
officially started a formal review
around the incident and will explore
further action and consequences in
accordance with our bylaws standards of
conduct and california law what exactly
those consequences may entail is not
entirely clear though deadline notes
that potential outcomes may include
barring smith from attending future
events including the 2023 oscars or
stripping him of his academy membership
according to the hollywood reporter
there was an emergency phone call the
morning after the ceremony with the
academy's board of governors but the
issue will likely be settled at the next
full meeting of the board as the first
such conference following the oscars
usually addresses any issues which took
place during the event the academy seems
reluctant to strip smith of his best
actor oscar citing chris rock's refusal
to press criminal charges against smith
academy governor whoopi goldberg weighed
in on the view we're not going to take
that oscar from him well we're not going
to say there's consequences to well
there will be consequences i'm sure
notably while the academy's recently
implemented code of conduct stipulates
that members must not violate recognized
standards of decency there is no formal
procedure for rescinding an award after
it has been presented as the academy
works to determine the best course of
action the social media world has lit up
with thoughts on both the given
statements and what the next steps
should be on one side some believe that
will smith should not only be held
accountable for his actions but he
should face a strong punishment as well
one twitter user posted the most public
stance that they can take is to ban him
from next year's oscars no exceptions
another user agreed posting don't take
his oscar but a public reprimand and
revoke of membership so there's
permanent loss of privileges on the
other hand more than a few people have
taken the time to vocally side with
smith as the academy continues to assess
the situation users have posted in
defense of smith with tweets like y'all
leave this man alone he was defending
his wife and nobody was there for a
roast he shouldn't have gone after jada
and smith was wrong to hit him but he
was also wrong to say what he did it
wasn't funny at all regardless of where
you may stand on it the will smith chris
rock ordeal has become nothing if not
messy all we can do is wait and see how
the academy chooses to follow up in the
wake of this polarizing incident check
out one of our newest videos right here
plus even more looper videos about the
latest hot topics are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one